[Música]
hablamos ahora de salud en directo
américa de france 24 y nos acompaña en
el estudio nuestra cronista marina
sardina marina el pasado miércoles se
celebró el día internacional de la
obstetricia y también de la embarazada
marina nosotros hoy vamos entonces a
hablar de un tema que todavía está muy
invisibilizado y se trata de la
violencia obstétrica no que sufren las
mujeres cuando van a dar a luz cuéntanos
de qué se trata esto buenos dias raúl si
efectivamente esta es una de las
violencias más desconocidas e
invisibilizadas pese a que también es
una de las violencias contra las mujeres
que más sufre especialmente pues las
mujeres cuando van a durante y antes del
trabajo de parto en muchas ocasiones la
mujer se convierte en un sujeto pasivo
una vez que cruza las puertas de una
sala de hospital la violencia obstétrica
es por ejemplo no respetar la decisión
de la madre en la forma en la que quiere
dar a luz practicar cesáreas
injustificadas o realizar maniobras
agresivas que afectan tanto a la salud
de la madre como del bebé la
problemática es que esta violencia está
muy naturalizada y arraigada en las
sociedades desde que en 2019 hasta
naciones unidas- raúl recon y lo
reconoció como un tipo de violencia
contra las mujeres y algunos países por
ejemplo en américa latina están
legislando para que no ocurra el primer
país de la región con una normativa
contra la violencia obstétrica fue
venezuela en 2017 pero también argentina
panamá méxico bolivia o brasil tienen
regularizaciones al respecto para hablar
de esto tenemos con nosotros desde
españa a marte a busquets ella es
abogada especialista en derecho género y
salud muchas gracias por estar con
nosotros marta en france 24 quería
preguntarte de qué se trata esta
violencia obstétrica y si nos puedes
poner unos ejemplos de estos casos
o las dudas muchas gracias por invitarme
en primer lugar yo creo que hay una
primera fase en el activismo en relación
a la violencia estética que tiene que
ver con el exceso de intervención o el
exceso de neutralización y aquí
podríamos pensar fácilmente un exceso de
test arias en los excesos e inducciones
que sobrepasen las recomendaciones
internacionales en la vida de las
mujeres aparece una serie de posturas
determinadas en realizar master
directiva de intervenciones sin que
exista necesidad del icai sólo por
rutina y que estas intervenciones pueden
ser potencialmente positivas y luego hay
una segunda fase o vertiente en el
turismo en relación a la ciencia o
estética que tiene que ver con una
perspectiva de sector más allá de la
intención científica de atractivos en
ciertas intervenciones y de las
estadísticas tenemos que tener en cuenta
que las mujeres algunas personas de
pleno derecho con derechos fundamentales
y que por lo tanto tenemos derecho a
informarnos a dar el consentimiento a
poder decidir qué tipo de parto queremos
tener en relación a nuestras criaturas
marta y por ejemplo cuéntanos cuáles
pueden ser las secuelas de por ejemplo
una episiotomía en la física y mental de
la madre y también estas prácticas tan
patriarcales que se denominan comúnmente
como por ejemplo el punto para el marido
no cuéntanos un poquito de esto
a menudo la fisionomía es una práctica
que esté paralizando el sentido de que
hasta hace poco y todavía muchos lugares
será una práctica que se hacía
totalmente de rutina a pesar de que
tiene que realizarse en momentos muy
concretos con indicaciones muy
específicas no y muchas mujeres relatan
y de hecho yo lo veo que consulta como
abogada pues lesiones serias en tu suelo
pélvico puede potencialmente estas
tensiones en el suelo pélvico causar y
pertinencias vías teórica clásica les
estoy causar dolores importantes puede
causar que esta mujer no pueda llevar a
cabo actividades como trabajar
establecer y es tentar a tener
relaciones sexuales satisfactorias se
filtra todo esto puede tener una
afectación realidad incluso si no tiene
una afectación a largo plazo el hecho de
que acaben de hacer una que se tome a
puede hacer que te pases un postparto
muy adolorida con dificultad para estar
sentado tumbarte por disputar para
amamantar con nuestras adolorida te
cuesta más recuperar te vincularse con
el bebé etcétera y lo del punto del
marido desgraciadamente también en
teoría sucede cada vez menos pero
sabemos que sigue sucediendo y hay
mujeres que relatan que este desear que
les ha hecho este comentario
el cual es lamentable y es violento
porque no tiene que ver con lo que
necesita el bienestar físico o psíquico
de una mujer es más directamente
convertir sus órganos sexuales o su
cuerpo en un lugar en el que la
actividad desde el placer asociado al
compañero masculino marta la salud un
gusto que estés con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24 le pregunto qué
derechos de la mujer se vulneran cuando
profesional de la salud ejerce este tipo
de violencia además que puedan hacer las
mujeres para buscar una reparación ante
este daño
la ciudad que es la convención para
licitación de las violencias contra las
mujeres etc tiene un protocolo en
relación a esta luz y dice que las
mujeres tenemos derecho a vivir nuestra
salud nuestras vidas de formas plena y
digna no cuando se atenta contra nuestra
salud se está atentando contra nuestro
derecho a vivir vidas plenas dignas de
etcétera y aquí obviamente hay
afectaciones de derechos que normalmente
pensamos en clave para su humano general
como por ejemplo si no me informan o mi
forma me pide de consentimiento para
realizar una intervención porque están
haciendo por ejemplo aceptar contar mi
integridad física o moral porque se está
llevando a cabo una intervención en el
cuerpo que yo no he consentido también
se si me hacen comentarios inhumanos
degradantes no me dejan deambular
etcétera también se puede estar
atentando no sé si me puede estar
realizando tratos inhumanos y
degradantes que ha disfrutado ha habido
algunas sentencias del tribunal europeo
de derechos humanos en este sentido con
lo cual puede haber hay una afectación
real de nuestros derechos también por
ejemplo en relacionada
si se comparten nuestros datos con
estudiantes nosotras no hemos permitido
que estos estudiantes accedan o nos
intervengan también se puede estar
llorando nuestra privacidad y el secreto
de nuestros datos médicos estaban en
sentencias del tour europeo de derechos
humanos en este sentido y como apuntaba
es el informe especial que realizó la
relatora de naciones unidas también
hablaba en este sentido y era cercana o
si estaba positivamente en relación a
esto
marta y que hace falta dentro de los
sistemas sanitarios para que esto no
ocurra qué tipo de no sé si hace falta
más pedagogía o una formación especial
para los personal sanitario de los
centros
el informe de la relatora de la onu hash
conscripción es que los estados tienen
que estar y los sistemas de salud
directamente responsables de lo que está
sucediendo y es verdad que sí que existe
mucho la pedagogía en la formación en el
relevo de profesionales parece ser que
las y los profesionales más jóvenes
están intentando cambiar las cosas pero
seguramente pasa también por políticas
públicas no pasa sólo por un tema de
formación en muchos países ha habido
recortes a nivel de presupuestos para
salud y esto qué significa menos equipos
equipos peor pagados un entorno más
implantado tanto a nivel de medios
materiales y personales esto repercute
directamente también en la la prestación
que se va a poder realizar porque yo por
mucho que quiera trabajar bien si estoy
sola hay que atender un ratio de mujeres
muy amplio y además no tengo medios
seguramente voy a acabar
inmersa en situaciones que están
violencia hacia las usuarias en este
tema también de que yo creo que no
tenemos resuelto qué hacer cuando una
mujer se queja de diversia o estética y
formas alternativas a la judicialización
en caso de mala praxis etcétera
de intervenir sobre esto también
desgraciadamente por ejemplo en españa
que ha habido esta reforma de ley sexual
y reproductiva por ejemplo no ha habido
ni siquiera consenso a nivel estatal
sobre el término de libertad estética
así que todavía queda un poco a nivel
político en este ámbito marca se nos
acaba el tiempo la tenemos que despedir
igual muchísimas gracias por estar con
nosotros esta mañana de viernes en
directo américa de france 24 un gran
abrazo
gracias para invitarme marta busquets
abogada especialista en derecho género y
salud marina también gracias a por toda
la información sobre esta violencia
obstétrica que tratamos el día de hoy
pasamos a saludar a nuestro segundo
invitado el día